[Musique]
et
cette semaine nos verivue lilloise
personnes se prénomme à steam et bastien
est une ressource devant un food truck
installé à montigny le bretonneux leur
hug au concept inédit bonjour à
vous deux bonjour team nicolas et
sébastien maillard bonjour à tous les
deux vous avez 22 ans originaire de
cette ville de montigny le bretonneux
vous êtes donc étudiants et en tant
qu'étudiant déjà vous avez fait un
constat la précarité alimentaire des
jeunes c'est devenu un vrai fléau vous
bastien vous étiez à la tête d'une
association justement la chargée de
promouvoir une alimentation saine et
responsable et c'est là que vous avez
fait un constat est que vous avez dit
vous devez agir la suite de l'histoire
je vous laisse la raconter tout à fait
alors du coup l année dernière j'étais
président de cette association composée
de la distribution de paniers de fruits
et légumes locaux sur les campus
donc on vendait ses paniers à des prix
hyper abordable on voulait que les
étudiants puissent manger sainement et
assez facilement et voilà le coc vide
est arrivé
bon j'avais en gros le temps pour faire
une césure l opportunité j'en ai parlé à
timothée et on s'est dit qu'on allait se
lancer dans un projet sur la césure de
foot rock pour lutter contre cette
précarité alimentaire des étudiants vous
avez créé donc monté tout ce projet se
fout de troc est juste derrière vous
pour aider ces étudiants comment ça
fonctionne simplement so foot prague
alors le concept il est assez simple
nous on va s'implanter tout et trois
semaines sur un campus étudiant sur ce
campus pendant trois semaines on va
rester tous les midis on proposera un
plat et un dessert n'y a pas de choix
c'est un plat qu'on aura préparé le
matin tout fait maison avec des produits
locaux fournis chez les producteurs du
coin et en parallèle à tout ça on va
mener des actions de sensibilisation
on va aider les associations qui vendent
des paniers de fruits et légumes locaux
on va les aider un peu à
haut niveau de la communication à
s'implanter à mieux se démarquer
et tout ça avec des repas vendu à
seulement 3 euros le midi alors
économiquement comment ça fonctionne
parce que vous travaillez avec des
produits locaux vous allez les chercher
auprès de producteurs vous avez déjà
tout un carnet d'adressés tout à fait
pour que l'on propose des plats des
menus à 3 euros un contenant plats
chauds et dessert il n'y a pas le choix
il faut déjà que le l'investissement
soit fait donc le foot rock ça coûte
très cher et c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
on a répondu à des appels à projets et
compétition pendant ces six derniers
mois on a levé donc des dizaines de
milliers d'euros de fonds pour
évidemment financer tout ça et on a
bouclé sa en fin juin
donc on est content pour ça ça et vite
sauf que le prix se répercute dans le
menu donc des frais d'amortissement de
matériel et pour les frais de de main
d'oeuvre en fait on est bénévole tous
les deux donc on peut proposer ses menus
à 3 euros et voilà avec des produits
locaux
qui ne tremble pas évidemment le
producteur par rapport au tarif qu'on
lui achète
voilà ces problèmes de précarité
alimentaire j'y reviens où vous vous y
êtes sensible depuis longtemps cédé
constat que vous avez pu faire auprès de
vos amis pendant vos études et qu'est-ce
qui vous sensibilise à ce sujet
particulièrement alors la précarité
alimentaire étudiante c'est quelque
chose on a toujours été un peu
confrontés mois de mai étudier pas mal
de gens qui n'est pas forcément beaucoup
de moyens après ça c'est vachement
accentuée pendant la crise qu vide et
c'est beaucoup aux infos qu'on l'a
vraiment ressenti vraiment beaucoup plus
et on s'est rendu compte que c'était
important d'agir et donc nous on l'avait
il voulait faire une césure ea n'a saisi
l'opportunité pour pour se rendre utile
pour lutter contre la précarité
alimentaire étudiantes alors parlons des
plats que vous préparez vous êtes vous
avez des formation de cuisinier
formation hôtelier pas du tout deux
formations timothée et dans
l'informatique
moi je n'en géniaux riz donc on n'est
pas du tout préparés à priori assad
après notre formation notre cursus mais
néanmoins on aime on adore cuisiner tous
les deux évidemment ce serait pas lancer
dans un tel projet sans ça et on apprend
sur le tas on essaye d'appeler être
accompagné par des cuisiniers d'avoir
des parrains de ce projet et puis comme
ça vers les réseaux le contact ben on a
des coups de main mais quel plat vous
avez préparé aujourd'hui c'était le on
aime septembre c'était le premier
service les étudiants sont venus vous
voir vous aurez vais proposer quoi alors
ce midi on a proposé des aubergines qui
sont caramélisées avec un mélange die
gingembre et sauce soja avec plein
d'autres épices da ciboulette et
s'asservir en sauce avec du riz et en
dessert un cookie ça c'est notre
spécialité où on en a fait un manager
cuisine et plus de 1000 donc c'est une
recette qu'on commence à maîtriser un
peu
[Musique]
alors nous sommes donc dans votre camion
justement dans votre food truck vous
nous faites une petite visite guidée
peut-être oui alors quand on rentre dans
le foutraque et on commence par se laver
les mains on enfile le tanguy le tablier
et puis du coup c'est se qu'on a
aménagé nous mêmes
donc tous les meubles ont été dix années
sur mesure et est coupé par nos soins
pendant ces deux mois de vacances où on
faisait ça les nuits et les week-ends
donc globalement on à
l'approvisionnement donc tout ce qui est
logistique qui au fond dans des cagettes
alimentaire vous avez rapidement trouvé
vos marques dans le food truck parce que
même si on aime faire la cuisine
l'agencement c'est un petit peu
différent en fait comme on agences et le
entièrement nous mêmes on a très
vite trouvé nos marques parce que on
sait exactement comment il est fait et
surtout on l'a fait par rapport à nos
besoins en fait chaque centimètre carré
a été rentabilisé pour ranger vos cinq
rangées dans un bidon d'eau en rab enfin
chaque centimètre carré te foutrais qui
est rentabilisé sur vos études vous fait
un break en ce moment vous l'avez dit
comment ça s'organise comment ça se
passe pour vous parce que on va re
situer un petit peu tout ce projet pour
reprendre du début donc vous lancez se
vous êtes sensible à la précarité
étudiante alimentaire pour autant c'est
pas votre formation le but c'est pas de
ces de le pérenniser mais en tout cas
vous de pouvoir reprendre vos études
comment vous organisez votre votre break
alors donc personnellement aux mines on
nous aide bien pour ça c'est assez
facile de se lancer dans ce genre de
projet
et puis voilà on avait un projet qui
était hyper bien construit et qu'on a pu
défendre aisément devant nos écoles
respectives pour timothée bon c'est un
peu différent l'école 42 et plus souple
et autorise ce genre de projet d'accord
et il a fallu lever des fonds aussi vous
l'avez dit 70000 euros presque donc
montigny-le-bretonneux vous a aidé mais
pas seulement puisque là nous sommes à
montigny sur la place cités de marseille
pour laquelle la première vente que vous
avez pu organiser mais le camion part
dans le grand est parce qu'ils vous ont
aidé aussi là-bas tout à fait donc on a
eu la chance de gagner certains appels à
projets très conséquents notamment que
le plan france relance on n'y a
bénéficié dans la région du grand test
dans le département de meurthe et
moselle on l université de lorraine
aussi qui nous accompagne financièrement
et en plus dans la recherche des
emplacements de foot rock est un élément
essentiel évidemment
voilà donc après des sponsors privés on
a aussi on a essayé de diversifier nos
apports financiers pour que l'on puisse
lever autant d'argent aussi rapidement
parce que c'est quand cinq mois qu'on a
réussi quand même et en plus c'était que
théoriques ont présenté évidemment des
dossiers et on n'avait pas idée de la
faisabilité même au gré des dizaines
d'appels il fallait que ça se passe quoi
ça a été plus ou moins facile je sais
pas si c'est le bon mot mais est-ce que
vous avez rencontré des difficultés à
vous écouter vous avez une projet vous
l'avez bien monté c'était très carrée et
c'était parti alors en fait des
difficultés pas exactement mais ça a été
très très long parce que la partie levée
de fonds ça a été deux mois où on passer
tout notre temps libre toutes nos
soirées tout le week end à remplir des
dossiers et il y a il ya plus marrant à
faire dans la vie vous a été très très
long on a dû faire 25 appels à projets
en tout énormément de pizzas faire mais
on n'a jamais été découragés parce qu'il
y avait toujours la motivation d'avoir
le projet au bout et on avant parlait le
plein de réunions et plein de plein de
trucs pour organiser aussi le reste du
projet pour le préparer de manière plus
concrète
donc on n'a pas eu tant de difficultés
par rapport à ça on a eu un peu de
stress de ne pas avoir l'argent parce
que finalement les résultats d'appels à
projets il arrive fin juin et le filtre
à qu'il fallait l'acheter assez
rapidement et le plus rapidement
possible mais sinon on s'en est plutôt
bien sorti l'aventuré va durer combien
de temps pour vous alors pour l'instant
ces six mois six mois de bénévolat
jusque février
après on essaye de nous on est à la
recherche activement deux repreneurs
donc d'étudiants motivés pour pareille
faire 6 mois ou plus ou mois sur des
campus de leur choix avec tout
l'équipement dont on a pu
acheter grâce à nos levée de fonds
et puis évidemment je pense qu'on sera
encore un peu dans la boucle pour
s'assurer que le projet tourne bien
peut-être s'il tourne vraiment très bien
on a des on a quelques idées pour le
rendre encore plus large plus d'ampleur
il ya quelque chose qui nous tient quand
même à coeur c'est que ce foutraque là
bon certes en cuisine le midi on est
actif sur les campus mais après on
essaye de challenge et du coup les
responsables sur les campus dans la
restauration universitaire sur les
régions pour que l'approvisionnement des
produits alimentaires soit beaucoup plus
source et localement voilà c'est quelque
chose qui nous tient à coeur qu'on
essaye de faire
là en ce moment et durant nos six mois
durant comment de foot ruck et ça risque
de continuer après donc si vous êtes
étudiant déjà que ou suivez cet
entretien vous pouvez solliciter donc
tim et bastien c'est marqué sur leurs
food truck pour reprendre et voilà
reprendre ce projet et le faire perdurer
c'est l'objectif aujourd'hui c'était
donc la première journée qu'elles sont
un peu les retours vous avez eue est ce
que vous vous êtes satisfait en tout cas
de cette première journée alors nous on
a assez satisfait on a fini de le
bricolage du foutraque hier soir donc on
était plutôt bien au niveau timing on
savait pas du tout à quoi s'attendre
finalement il ya pas mal d'étudiants qui
sont venus on a réussi à écouler à peu
près tous les tous les repas qu'on
voulait les étudiants qui sont venus
étaient vraiment intéressés il s'était
intéressé par le projet il était
intéressé par par exemple le fait que
tous nos coûts nous tenons soit
compostables pour essayer de limiter les
déchets et c'était vraiment une très
très bonne première journée très bien
merci à tous les deux le mot de la fin
ce sera justement pour les clients que
vous avez pu avoir aujourd'hui les
étudiants sommes alors demandé ce qu'il
pensait justement de ceux de ce
fonctionnement de ce concept et puis les
plats que vous avez pu proposer merci
encore à vous via un site internet team
bastient point fr et on se retrouve
bientôt sur tv 78 et surtout si tu vas
me l'initiative j'avais su à des jeunes
qui tiennent ça et
et quitte à se ils font attention aussi
à l'environnement il me semble donc
c'est toujours bien ouais c'est trop
cool en fait en plus le tarif d'accès
pour les étudiants donc c'est une quête
pour nous on sent que ça a été cuisiné
avec amour
non mais c'est vrai c'est important du
coup ça fait un repas repas correct pour
des bons des étudiants qui ont pas
forcément des gros moyens
[Musique]